merci je vais commencer mon intervention
tout de suite pas vous dire que je
n'avais pas prévu de devenir
entrepreneur
je n'avais pas choisi je n'avais pas
décidé ce n'était pas organisée je suis
devenu entrepreneur simplement parce que
j'ai voulu aider les autres c'est ange
vouloir emmener les jeunes à créer leur
propre emploi que moi même je me suis
retrouvé à créer mon propre emploi
alors la vie nous enseigne les choses
mon parcours entreprenariale m'a appris
beaucoup de choses
la conviction aujourd'hui et que la
meilleure manière de se servir soi même
et de servir le monde la meilleure
manière de s'aider soi-même et d'aider
les autres et c'est pour ça c'est en
voulant aider les autres que moi même je
suis arrivé à créer mon propre emploi
c'est pas parce que je n'avais pas
essayé à un moment donné c'est pas aussi
parce que
j'avais pas pensé
simplement parce que j'avais peur
j'avais peur de me lancer de faire le
premier pas
parce que quelque part j'ai compris
aussi que
quand tu connais plus tu connais la
chose plus tu as peur de l'affronter moi
j'ai passé toute ma carrière
professionnelle à accompagner les jeunes
à les former je suis formateur depuis
j'ai formé des jeunes j'ai été à la tête
d'un fonds de financement de plusieurs
milliards ou j'ai financé des projets de
jeux de conakry jusqu'à zérékoré je
connais ce métier j'ai travaillé sur les
questions de matraques je conseille j'ai
encouragé à entreprendre mais moi
j'avais peur parce que simplement je
mettais ma motivation sur des calculs
financiers je me disais est ce que j'ai
à les rentabiliser je vais poser la
question est ce que j'allais trouver le
financement
parce que je sais comme une fois c'est
difficile est-ce que je peux trouver le
client plus tard est ce que est ce que
est ce que et donc que j'avais peur
parce que je n'avais pas toutes les
réponses tout de suite moi j'avais un
emploi je travaillais donc je me disais
mon jeu prend pas le risque en attendant
et donc à force de poser ces questions
je me dis je vais le ramener à plus tard
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
un jour c'était le 27
c'était le mois de septembre 2017
j'ai eu un sentiment de ras le bol parce
que simplement les informations assez à
ces dates là tout ce qui se passait
c'était au tour de l'immigration
irrégulière tout ce qu'on disait tout ce
qu'on voyait dans le quartier est
partout c'était des jeunes qui sont
morts
dans la baie rouen dans le désert
et pour ça quand j'ai vu ça à un moment
donné je me suis dit mais qu'est ce qui
se passe moi je peux pas rester sans
rien faire
parce que quand on est en face de ces
informations de ces images on a deux
manières de lire l'information soit on
se dit que
c'est l'état qui n'a pas fait son job
c'est la corruption c'est la mal
gouvernance donc recherche a accusés ont
cherché à indexer quelqu'un moi j'ai une
autre manière de lire les informations
quand je vois ça je me dis qu'est-ce que
je peux faire pour participer pour
contribuer
et ça je vous dis ça a été la meilleure
question que je supposais toute ma vie
parce que c'est elle a changé toute ma
carrière à partir de là je me suis dit
mais à quoi bon avoir toutes ces
expertises
formateur expert en financement tout ça
si tu ne peux rien apporté pour aider
ces jeunes si à ce moment que je me suis
décidée alors faut faire quelque chose
et j'ai lancé le concept aux taux
d'emploi c'était juste une initiative
citoyenne juste pour participer à ma
manière
et donc
aux stones emploi c'était de dire aux
jeunes toi qui peux lever des fonds
auprès de ta famille pour financer t'as
ton aventure de dans l'immigration
irrégulière tu peux lever un fonds
auprès de table même famille pour
financer sa propre activité ton aventure
entrepreneuriale c'était donc ce schéma
que moi j'amène un et donc j'ai mené des
activités et auprès des jeunes autour du
thé dans les quartiers c'est à dire que
au lieu de parler de politique je les
emmenais simplement à parler de
l'entrepreneuriat et ça ça dure et j'ai
évolué comme ça je le faisais
gratuitement pendant que je ne
travaillais pas donc mes heures libres
et puis je suis allé plus loin
et c'est à ce moment que j'ai rencontré
il faut le reconnaître aussi madame la
directrice nationale emplois jeunes qui
a cru en moi parce que j'avais conçu une
petite vidéo de sensibilisation
c'était en corse dans un téléphone c'est
rien du tout et elle me dis tout de
suite on peut publier ça sur le style de
vie ministère de la jeunesse et je vous
dis c'est parti de là et après je suis
allé plus loin parce que et elle m'a
fait tellement confiance elle a accepté
avec l'appui du ministre à l'époque de
me prêter la salle de réunion pour y
mêler mes activités de formation et
l'autre tous les samedis
quand je travaillais pas les 110 je
venais donner d'informations sur
l'entrepreneuriat la création d'une
start up donc des activités de
sensibilisation
j'ai mené comme ça ses activités pendant
plusieurs semaines et j'ai réussi à
former gratuitement 257 jeune
c'était beaucoup j'ai vu aussi le
potentiel et j'ai vu ce que je suis
capable de faire je peux apporter une
contribution
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe moi je ne
savais pas que ces activités que je
faisais gratuitement
et de surcroît pendant mes heures livre
pouvait me coûtait ou ans mais mon
emploi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé moi je
travaillais dans un incubateur
alors la jetée j'occupais le poste le
business developer et puis pendant ce
moment là j'étais aussi le directeur par
intérim parce que la directice à
l'époque était en congé de maternité
-la pendant six mois j'ai vraiment gérer
l'incubateur à la fois accompagner les
entrepreneurs et aussi faire fonctionner
l'administration de l'incubateur pendant
six mois bon moi je me disais que j'ai
fait un bon travail et quelque part je
peux m'attendre à les remercier a déjà
une augmentation de salaire peut-être
comme tout bon travailleur
qu'est ce qui se passe au premier
contact quand elle est revenue
bonjour on fait un point aujourd'hui à
midi
hélas toutes mes idées sur
l'augmentation de salaire sur les
remerciements au nom quitté parce que
c'était pas ça à l'ordre du jour alors
au moment venu elle m'a fait savoir que
c'était pas possible de prendre cette
idée
cette initiative citoyenne et de la m
sein de l'incubateur
désir mans c'était pas possible et que
je devais choisir entre mon emploi et
motivés
mais là
encore une fois c'était inattendu
j'étais face à moi-même parce que moi je
disais aux jeunes il faut croire en toi
et il faut créer un emploi faut pas
courir derrière un emploi parce que tu
veux pas en trouver en a pas pour tout
le monde il faut payer et donc là la vie
nous amène à choisir entre mon emploi et
ma conviction oui et là
il fallait que je sois
cohérent avec moi même
fallait que je sois logique avec mon
engagement avec les jeunes
finalement je sois vu mon bébé
je n'avais pas prévu je n'étais pas prêt
financièrement même j'étais pas
organiser mais fallait donc faire de
cette idée une structure
et donc pour me présenter je suis
d'hendaye à l'eau
je suis le fondateur et le directeur de
l'incubateur hausse de l'emploi qui a
aujourd'hui créer six emplois qui est
représenté à la fois à conakry à kindia
mamou et labé
aujourd'hui j'accompagne dans les
différents locaux de l'incubateur plus
de 75 jeunes
aujourd'hui grâce à leurs activités
on a pu impacter toucher directement
plus de 2000 jeunes
on a pu lever plus de 800 millions pour
financer directement les projets des
jeunes
et ça ne fait que avancer parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a la confiance de
beaucoup de partenaires tels que l'eau y
est telle que le nude à commencer
d'abord par le ministère la jeunesse
tels que tel que tels que orange la
fondation orange il est si la suite qui
nous ont fait confiance pour les
accompagner
et donc c'est là que j'ai appris que
la meilleure manière de se servir c'est
en servant les autres moi j'ai compris
ça et c'est sans la conviction
aujourd'hui je veux servir le monde ma
mission c'est le servir c'est donc
d'accompagner et c'est aider les jeunes
et c'est partant de sa queue puisque
l'histoire encore nous interpelle à
nouveau
c'est devenu ma mission
aujourd'hui je fais également un autre
constat
quand je regarde
les mêmes entrepreneurs qu'on est en
train d'accompagner
pour ne pas qu'il parte mourir à mai
ces mêmes entrepreneurs sont en train de
tout perdre ici aujourd'hui parce que
quelque part il y à une destruction de
leur exploitation quelque part
celui qui tue dans l'entreprise est en
train de te tuer quelque part
ces jeunes qui sont dans le secteur
agricole ces jeunes que nous
accompagnons tous ces jeunes que nous
encourageons tous les jours et les temps
même en premier parce que le
gouvernement a pris comme initiative
le développement de l'agriculture le
développement de l'entrepreneuriat gel
mais il se trouve que ces mêmes jeunes
qu'on a encouragé sont en train de
perdre leur exploitation quelque part
parce que ces bulles et j'avais emmené
une photo je sais pas s'il veut suis
pour faire sortir ça
ils sont en train de perdre ça se passe
aujourd'hui moi en face de ces
informations comment je les lis je me
dis qu'est-ce que je peux faire
voilà ma réaction et c'est pour ça j'ai
aussi lancé le concept protège nos
récoltes parce que ses récoltes c'est à
la fois
les fluides et exploitation de ces
jeunes c'est à la fois les emplois créés
c'est à la fois les revenus partagés
donc c'est à la fois pour les
communautés et pour les jeunes
donc je me dis quelques pages je dois
agir voilà la mission et j'ai qu'en
donnant ici je me suis dit je pourrais
aussi avoir parce que je veux servir le
monde et je veux pas le faire tout seul
je pourrais avoir les personnes
sensibles à cette situation qui vont le
faire avec moi et c'est pour ça je vais
vous demander simplement pour ceux qui
sont sensibles à cette situation de vous
lever s'il vous plaît et de 10 avec moi
je veux servir le monde
s'il vous plaît
allez-y s'il vous plaît je veux servir
le monde
protégeons nos récoltes
protégeant nos écoles
je vous remercie